[Music]
tapes juan you're new here right cool
i'm connor uh what are your pronouns uh
mine are
i'm a big michael jackson fan you know
anyway as it's your first day as a
janitor at the wulk central park let me
walk you through some guidelines of ours
that the nrpa introduced lately don't
just stand there come on i'll show you
around
so you must have heard about our
handicapable guide for interacting with
visitors let me check if you got
everything right see those guys right
there how'd you call them
homeless people check your privilege
miguel these are on house from the
emergency shletter you mean shelter are
you legally blind it says right here
some preferring the term emergency
shelter bienden what about that group
over there abuelitos playing with their
nitos antonio we don't use curse words
around here god where are you from texas
from cuba actually they're clearly older
adults giving care to their younger
adults we don't use aegis terms around
here just promise me you'll look through
the guide again i'll lend you a copy oh
that reminds me of something we do
firmly believe land acknowledgements do
not exist in the past tense or
historical context colonialism is a
current ongoing process and we need to
build our mindfulness of our present
participation hey you diverse group of
indigenous people get the hell off the
lawn see how i use the term indigenous i
believe those were indian americans sir
that's why i added the diverse group
part you never know these days actually
the guide suggests we call them the same
way we call plants you can't just say
invasive or alien plants nowadays you
say long established or indigenous you
see so you basically compare people to
weeds no well sort of the guide states
so i'm not racist i even asked the
management to pull the turkey sandwiches
from the shelves during thanksgiving we
don't even celebrate thanksgiving since
it can be really traumatic to vulnerable
people why is the text on the sign
written so funny what's so funny about
that the word black is capitalized oh
you didn't know the capitalized term
black reflects a shared identity and
culture rather than a description of
skin color and why is the word white
lowercase then juan you really need to
read up on our guidelines again see it
says right there the term white should
be lowercase plato but it's just the
name of some plants alien plants people
and weeds remember and since we are on
this topic let me remind you it's
undocumented to say illegal about a
person sorry it's illegal to call
someone undocumented
we prefer the term a person with complex
immigration status like you oh i
completely forgot uh do you want me to
refer to you as a latinx member of our
board latinx yeah use the term in
california how do you pronounce it in
spanish we don't i apologize it must be
my implicit bias speaking but i can't do
anything about it the guide says our
biases are activated involuntarily and
internal control is not accessible
through introspection i'm trying my best
here so pardon me in advance do you
think i'm racist no just the stupido god
spanish is such a beautiful language
anyway we are done here here's your
broom i'll go and brief my colleagues on
structural racism and social power so
i'll see you later miguel it's juan just
remember our guidelines jose
you